foreign
what I'm trying to make friends with the aliens
is it just my Tick Tock algorithm or are we
like six to 24 months out from some kind of
apocalyptic event I mean 2020 was depressing
AF but at least back then we were just doing
dances on Tick Tock now my feed is filled with
all these six parters about solar flares and
climate change to Deuce natural disasters and
cyber warfare economic depression human rights
reversals new viral pandemics and alien
invasions like oh my God I almost died
it's all right it's all right at this point
I'm kind of rooting for the aliens because it
all just feels so damn Bleak and even though
I think some of these are legitimate timely
concerns I've never been a doomsday prepper
like my anxiety is bad enough on a good day
I feel like I would kind of just prefer to
not think about all the terrible ways that
Society could collapse in the next five
to ten years but I'm starting to think
that maybe those guys are kind of onto something
no but seriously folks nothing wrong with having
some cheap and cheerful Pantry meals on standby
for whatever minor or major world event we
encounter next so while I'm not exactly at the
point of Readiness to learn how to hunt squirrels
or raccoons I'll show you how a dietitian will
build out balanced meals in a hypothetical
post-apocalyptic World hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's future bunker [Music]
thank you I don't know if I'm laughing because
I'm joking or because I'm taking this so seriously
that it scares the [__] out of me but hey if
nothing else the meals that I would make in like a
hypothetical post-apocalyptic scenario are really
meals that could save me some serious coin in the
current climate where I just paid nine dollars
for a bunch of half rotten asparagus that's where
we're at folks now quick disclaimer here folks
I'm trying to keep this light and fun let's not
get into politics or conspiracy theories in the
comments I am definitely not trying to downplay
the seriousness of a lot of these worldly
issues but I'm also trying to not perpetuate
fear-mongering or conspiracy I have my own
personal fears and concerns for our world but I'm
not going to be getting into those today so please
do the same in the comments so you know use this
as your entertainment or as legitimate educational
awareness to complement whatever prepper tips you
find from legitimate Preppers online I'm just
personally interested in taking up the challenge
myself so let's go shopping but let me pop in here
quick folks I'm super excited to be working with
element again this is a product that I was using
like two years ago when I was on my breastfeeding
Saga and it really really helped me recover and I
got back into it recently because I've been out in
the sun I've been traveling a lot this summer and
I'm really really prone to sunstroke and I found
this makes a huge difference in how I feel a lot
of my colleagues who work in Sports Nutrition also
swear by elements specifically because it's got
a science-backed electrolyte ratio of a thousand
milligram sodium 200 milligrams potassium and
60 milligrams magnesium and it's got no colors
sugars or fillers I've also found that having
my electrolytes in the morning has had a really
positive impact on my sleep so even on days where
I'm not sweating a lot I'm usually still going
to have at least half a packet I love all things
spicy so the mango chili is my current Obsession
but I've got nine different flavors including
their new grapefruit which I love and it's now
available year round right now element is offering
my viewers a free sample pack with any order
so that's eight single serving packets free with
any element order this is a great way to try all
eight of their flavors or share element with a
salty friend get yours at drinkelement.com Abby
sharp and remember this is only available
through my link so you've got to go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-n-t.com slash ABI shark so in
preparation for this video I watched a bunch of
like Doomsday prepper videos on Tick Tock and they
were saying that there's a big difference between
Panic buying like we did with toilet paper
during the pandemic and curating a carefully
planned Pantry for a scenario where a we don't
have access to perishables from the grocery store
on the regular and B we don't have electricity so
we don't have any way to keep perishables cold and
we also don't really have any way to cook them on
a stovetop or in a microwave so basically we gotta
think about building meals and finding ingredients
that could be cooked very quickly on gas or
on an open fire if you're really hardcore and
that don't require any Refrigeration so let's
start with our protein list I would be stocking
up on protein powder canned tuna canned chicken
lentils canned beans peanut butter nuts bone broth
hemp hearts powdered milk nutritional yeast and
shelf stable Dairy next let's talk about produce
it may not be pretty but I would be going for a
canned vegetables canned fruits freeze-dried
fruits and dried fruits or dates we also have
to think about whole grains I'd be looking for
a quick cooking grains like white rice quick
cooking oats couscous or short cut pasta whole
grain crackers nutrient dense high fiber cereal
and obviously boxed mac and cheese sure it's not
whole grain but it's damn Delicious and for fats
obviously we'd be looking for shelf staple oils
like Olive or coconut oil okay post-apocalyptic
bunker Pantry stocked let's make some meals okay
so seeing as 95 of our meal Inc ingredients are
canned goods I'm trying to find my can opener
and for the life of me oh she's I got it
oh this is the only thing that matters if you
didn't have a can opener in the apocalypse
you're dead Okay you're just dead so make sure
you have a backup is what I'm saying oh oh
I was just texting all of my apocalyptic neighbors
and in a real apocalypse they probably would be
like off also we probably would not have cell
phones so yeah never mind I found it smiley face
an opener two learn how to use it I've had
a lot of employees over the years and none
of them know how to use my can opener it takes
a Special Touch which is why in The Apocalypse
I will survive no maybe not yeah okay so before
the Wasps descend we're gonna make some oatmeal
now I have to be honest I've never cooked
anything other than meat and vegetables on
my barbecue we're gonna call this apocalypse
light because I'm not gonna build a fire from
scratch in my downtown backyard so we're gonna
cook this over gas outside I probably need
an oven mitt I'm pretty sure that would be
important I got some oats here Pantry staple
cheap and cheerful nice pick the wrong shirt guys
I've got some canned evaporated milk smells good
mmm sweet this is a bit of a bougie apocalypse
but let me tell you folks I'd be stocking up on
this you want to talk Panic buying this is the
aisle I'm going for forget the toilet paper you
know forget that the vegetables I'm going straight
for the hemp hearts you guys know that obviously
put some of that in there let's
do some peanut butter oh she's hot
so many mistakes have been made already like
I'm so ill prepared for this cooking session I'm
sweating I don't have anywhere to put my utensils
down that's relatively clean and that's out here
maple syrup because when you're having
a rough day you know spoonful of sugar
makes the medicine go down that's what they
say so I'm gonna put a little bit of water
we would have carbon filters in the apocalypse
right I would I'm gonna pop a lid on
go get another mint maybe turn that up I'm gonna
slide it a few moments later oh we did it okay
okay I'm more worried about the
WASP than I am about dying by
rabid animal okay I've got some
protein powder here obviously
we would have protein powder I
would at least maybe you would too
the fear of this scenario
is making me a little wonky
I'm just I'm moving my feet I'm scared scared
they're gonna get me oh yeah it's gonna be good
all right let's serve her up what I'm hot and
I'm bothered I'm not cut out for this life guys
I'm just not okay so realistically I feel
like you wouldn't want to waste more water
cleaning a dish so we gotta eat out of
here I've got some freeze-dried berries
I mean these would be perfect for
a post-apocalyptic scenario because
they crunchy they sweet they last literally
forever I don't even know but I think we'll
be okay and now we have to carefully eat this oh
my God okay I think it's one of these situations
all right
it's good pop you want to try
a bit hot so give it a little give it a blow
sharing is caring you got to keep those fur
babes alive too success I had to change
my outfit because I was sweating buckets
and y'all know we don't have enough water to
go around so this was necessary all right folks
let's make lunch and of course we're gonna
do some mac and cheese we're just waiting
for the post-apocalyptic construction to die
down here the aliens are building their home
next obviously mac and cheese okay because if
I'm going down I'm taking my mac and cheese
with me okay we love a good convenience
meal around here so let's cook some pasta
I guess we got no more clean water I gotta let
that come to a boil I'm losing my mind here
okay so that literally took a million hours and I
almost was stung about 20 million times during the
episode well we got pasta now we flavor it up so
a little while ago there was a ton of talk about
how boxed mac and cheese was filled with falfait
phaltates phthalates I can never say it right
phthalates which as I talked about in my video
are those endocrine disrupting chemicals that
we want to cut back on so I'm pretty sure if it
was the end of the world I wouldn't give a [__]
but because I am going to probably serve
this to my kids later my little hack is
to use just a little bit of the cheese
powder because this is where the edcs
are and then I flavor it up with other stuff
we're going to throw in our evaporated milk
struggle such a throttle okay I got some
nutritional yeast and that's going to stand in for
some of that cheesy powder plus it's going to add
lots of B12 and some protein give that a stir I've
also got some shelf stable grated cheese product
I've never really understood what this is but uh
yeah again in an apocalypse not sure I would care
if it tastes cheesy I'm here for it tiny tiny bit
of coconut oil in lieu of the butter note to self
in an apocalypse maybe get some dairy cows because
I'd be missing that all right I've got some white
kidney beans this is going to stand in for a good
amount of protein plus some extra fiber you gotta
stay regular when you're trapped in a bunker with
people that you've basically exclusively only
been hanging out with for Lord knows how long
and then I've got some canned vegetables and
I always forget about canned vegetables I mean
it smells a little bit like a nursing home
which is depressing in itself but we still
need to get our badge in folks so this will do
the trick just gonna add some more cheese on top
just dump the whole thing honestly when in doubt
just add more cheese it makes everything better
we all know that you don't need the Russian food
or anything no we don't need to ration food at all
here this is one day of Apocalypse folks just
one okay um let's serve her up I'm pretty sure
we already used up all of our dishwashing water
on hydrating me after I almost had heat stroke
wearing a sweater in the middle of summer but
here we are and I'm actually excited about this
[Music]
um I can get down with this the white beans are
really nice they add a nice like little bit of a
texture and chew um you're gonna be into this
the kids are getting into this too probably a
little for you and then we save the rest for
the Kinders she's into it I need you Poppy
I need you alright everyone it is dinner time and
we are starting with a staple rice it literally
took me two hours to cook this and what I've
learned is that it probably would have taken
me a lot less time to learn how to build an
actual open fire to cook over than it did to
make rice on my barbecue regardless here we
are we got some rice which I may or may not
have overcooked no it's perfect it's perfect
I've got some light skip Jack tuna I usually
buy skipjack over albacore because it's lower in
Mercury though I'm pretty sure in an apocalypse
scenario I wouldn't give it we got some canned
mushrooms honestly I kind of forgot how many
great options there are in the supermarket in
the canned vegetable and fruit department so we
got lots of ways to get our fiber in folks we got
some can oh geez that's gonna stink for a while
canned beans it'd be nice if they oh my gosh guys
look at this there's a rogue mushroom in my green
beans Walmart get your [__] together and then
I got these cute little baby corn those came in
a can as well nice now a few key condiments I
feel would be important if you're living in the
apocalypse soy sauce being one of them so we're
gonna give a little bit of that and I like to do
like a kind of salty sweet combination so I've
got a little maple syrup and then that's gonna
be hot I just know it we're gonna mix it all
up so to recap we've got our carbs here very
important for energy if we did need to run away
from I don't know like a zombie an alien another
human a bear I don't know what's going to be out
there folks but we gotta learn how to run is all
I know we got our carbs we have some protein in
our tuna plus some Fiber in all the veg I threw
in there and then I'm gonna top it off with some
healthy fats some cashews I might be lacking some
color but I feel like we're just gonna have to get
used to that I feel like this YouTube video could
be titled a myriad of ways either post apocalypse
meals or college meals or cheap and cheerful meals
I think there's lots of benefits to coming
up with things you can make from your pantry
oil pop you're gonna love this get it get it get
it get it I mean we might be struggling but I feel
like Poppy's gonna be all right all right finally
we got to dessert and I'm not sure how your
priorities stock up in a post-apocalyptic world
but I mean I feel like enjoyment and pleasure
in what's left of this life is high out there for
me so I don't know maybe I would just eat s'mores
maybe that would be all that I wanted to eat
regardless I'm definitely having dessert so
let's roast some marshmallow
on my Barbie eventually oh no
mistakes have already been made I'm usually
like a full bird to a crisp give me all the
carcinogens kind of marshmallow gal
but on the barbecue that's going to
take me all effing day and we need to
save our energy for I don't know like
whatever else you get up to when the world
is ending it's gonna have to be good enough
the makeup is just running off my face
note to self don't wear makeup in Apocalypse
oh she's coming she's gone that's what she said
why don't we just do this all year round I
gotta really re-evaluate my priorities in life
because I feel like s'mores should be an everyday
we're still here living Our Lives kind of thing
obviously it doesn't have all the nutrition
that you need but sometimes you just need
a little bit of pleasure to get you to
that next day and s'mores I don't know
it would do it for me well folks I'm not sure if I
feel inspired ill-prepared anxious or just I guess
happy that I was able to make a full day of meals
on the cheap a reminder here that I'm not trying
to downplay the seriousness of these worldly
issues and I'm also trying not to perpetuate
fear-mongering or conspiracy so just a friendly
reminder to take this video for whatever works
for you so I guess if we can use this for nothing
else and I hope that we use this for nothing else
let this be a grocery guide for the days when
things get financially tough minus the hemp
hurts because yeah that might not be realistic
but on that note I think I'm gonna go Google how
to build a fire so I hope that you guys enjoyed
this video it was fun for me to think about even
though at the same time it's kind of scary to
have to think about but if you guys like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up if you'd
like some more Pantry meals for whatever reason
apocalypse aliens a solution to the price gouging
that is happening in grocery stores today let me
know in the comments below and don't forget
to hit up my description for my 300 crushing
comic book ebook and I'll see you next time
on Abby's bunker beam me up foreign [Music]